today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
last night was night three of the
democratic national convention and
former president barack obama gave what
was by all reasonable assessments a very
solid dnc
speech in support of joe biden and
kamala harris
and very strongly going after donald
trump
and barack obama i mean listen you don't
have to think he was the best president
you don't have to think that joe biden's
the best candidate but
barack obama did not show up with kid
gloves
in criticizing donald trump you're going
to see clips in a moment but
donald trump within minutes if not
seconds of barack obama's speech
starting
was completely and instantly triggered
starting to send out outrageous tweets
in
all caps more the behavior
of a child really than an adult never
mind
an adult who happens to be the president
of the united states you can imagine the
scene
trump sitting at the white house obama
comes up on his screen and starts
dismantling donald trump pointing out
his failings and his
fundamental lack of capacity for the job
piece by piece by piece
trump grabs his phone turns on caps lock
as so many trumpists often do when it's
time to tweet
and then tweets he spied on my campaign
and got caught referring i guess
to the supposed biggest political crime
in
history which i can't even say it with a
straight face
which we still haven't gotten the
details of or been able to identify and
then
just moments thereafter as barack obama
continues speaking in full sentences
and putting together coherent thoughts
which is a very
uh unusual thing from a president at
this point in time trump tweets again
with caps capslock still
engaged why did he refuse to endorse
slow joe until it was all over
and even then was very late why did he
try to get him not to run
so the second part why did obama try to
convince joe not to run
that's bs but the reason barack obama
decided not to endorse joe biden or
anybody during the primary was the
calculation
and arguably it's a politically astute
calculation that
if barack obama gets involved in the
primary
and then whoever he supports doesn't end
up being the nominee
it could end up being divisive and it
could end up hurting barack obama's
ability
to then endorse and campaign for the
eventual nominee
it's a political calculation you can
disagree with it or not but that's all
it is barack obama's priority was and
is to defeat donald trump and barack
obama made the call
he's a better player in that cause
by staying out of the primary and
getting involved in support of the
eventual nominee which is what he did
there's really nothing controversial
there but if you want to go in that
direction
we should ask the question why hasn't
george w
bush gotten involved at all in helping
donald trump get reelected
and of course george w bush is not
supporting trump
in the sense of publicly as we've heard
in a statement from
a staffer of george w bush's and
certainly is not helping donald trump
get reelected what about that
that is a question that should be asked
now barack obama's speech
was followed during night three of the
dnc
by vice presidential pick kamala harris
democratic senator from california
and donald trump also triggered by her
and tweeting erratically
still with the caps lock engaged saying
quote
but didn't she call him a racist
referring to kamala and joe biden
didn't she say he was incompetent
some clips from barack obama's speech
that went right after donald trump this
is probably
part of the moment that
most triggered donald trump
donald trump hasn't grown into the job
because he can't
and the consequences of that failure are
severe
170 000 americans dead
millions of jobs gone while those at the
top
taken more than ever
our worst impulses unleashed
our proud reputation around the world
badly diminished
and our democratic institutions
threatened like never before
obama treating trump almost like a
little kid
saying i you know i had hopes that he
would
take the jobs it's like the the the
hopes were so pathetically low
people were hoping trump would take the
job seriously
and he didn't people were hoping trump
would grow into the job
and he didn't and then barack obama
continuing
i never expected that my successor would
embrace my vision
or continue my policies
i did hope for the sake of our country
that donald trump might show some
interest
in taking the job seriously
that he might come to feel the weight of
the office
and discover some reverence for the
democracy
that had been placed in his care
but he never did
for close to four years now he has shown
no
interest in putting in the work no
interest in finding common ground
no interest in using the awesome power
of his office to help
anyone but himself and his friends
also going after the trump
administration
on the basis of their playing very fast
and loose
with democracy work will continue long
after this election
but any chance of success depends
entirely
on the outcome of this election
this administration has shown it will
tear our democracy down
if that's what it takes for them to win
so we have to get busy building it up
by pouring all our efforts into these 76
days
so overall barack obama's speech was
fine
it emphasized donald trump's failings
uh and the constitution the weight
of the office of the presidency and the
responsibility that comes with it i
think it was a good speech
i actually think michelle obama's speech
on monday night
resonated more in terms of sort of
lighting a fire
about the acute nature of this situation
the emergency of a total deficit of
morality and decency and empathy in the
white house so
in a sense certainly barack obama a
master orator
michelle obama also a great speaker but
i actually thought that
overall maybe michelle obama's speech
was better suited for communicating the
urgency of the situation
although listen i miss hearing complete
sentences from a president
we heard complete sentences from barack
obama this is how low the bar is
i miss hearing coherent thoughts
expressed in those
complete sentences and we heard some
from barack obama
and you know we're really talking about
details now now last thing about the
obama speech
barack obama mentioned that even when
the democratic system
appears not to work our ancestors our
predecessors may be better said
still managed to use those arguably
uh flawed systems successfully to affect
change
this was this didn't get a lot of
attention from the speech
it is so poignant right now so i want to
play this is about 90 seconds from
barack obama's speech
listen very closely to what he says here
i think this is really crucial
what we do echoes
through generations
whatever our backgrounds we are all the
children of americans who fought the
good fight
great grandparents working in fire traps
and sweatshops without rights
or representation farmers
losing their dreams to dust
irish and italians and asians and
latinos told
go back where you come from
jews and catholics muslims and sikhs
made to feel suspect for the way they
worshipped
black americans chained and whipped
and hanged spit on
for trying to sit at lunch counters
beaten for trying to vote
if anyone had a right to believe that
this democracy did not work
and could not work it was those
americans
our ancestors they were on
the receiving end of a democracy that
had fallen short
all their lives
they knew how far the daily reality of
america strayed from the mint
and yet instead of giving up they joined
together
and they said somehow some way we are
going to make this work
we are going to bring those words
in our founding documents to life
this is so key right now because
we are trying to fix a problem
with a system that we don't have huge
confidence in
postal service voter suppression
reducing our early voting all the stuff
we've been covering
and we're saying we have a real problem
that we've got to fix but part of the
problem needs to be fixed
with a system that is part of what needs
repair as well will a broken system
allow us to actually fix it
uh and barack obama very um
poignantly says presciently says if
anyone had a right to believe that this
democracy didn't work and could not work
it was our ancestors those americans who
were on the receiving end of a democracy
that fell
short and he said they knew
how far the daily reality of america
strayed from the myth of america
and they didn't give up they didn't bail
and say
screw it they joined together and said
let's figure out how to make this work
that applies to this situation which is
we have to use
a system that donald trump has
manipulated for his own gain
to get him out and the answer is
you know what i'm going to say we have
to so overwhelm
the vote that the ways trump has
fixed and by fixed i don't mean repaired
i mean
uh uh sort of rigged the
election will not be enough to put him
in the oval office for an additional
four years we have to figure out how to
do that we can use this system to remove
trump
we just really have to come out in force
and a little bit later on
we are going to talk about how 2016's
non-voters
are looking at this election very
interesting
so that was night three of the dnc join
me tonight for night for
the final night of the dnc this is
really important this next story
when there's a conclusion of sorts to a
major
story it's really important to follow up
on it and this week what some previously
dismissed with this stupid term
russiagate
has been confirmed as very much not a
hoax and you know it never gets as much
attention when the report comes out
because you've got to read it
the corrections never get as much
attention as the headlines we know this
is a reality in media
but the senate select committee has
published its report about russian
meddling in the 2016 election
and it confirmed a lot now i'm not
expecting any apologies from the
lunatics who personally attacked me
and misstated what i claimed was the
situation
this is not about me but i hope that we
can get into the record
all of the things that were not a hoax
and were very much true
and what the senate report found is a
direct continuation of where robert
mueller's investigation
arguably stopped short and didn't go far
enough
we got the fifth and last volume of the
report on russia yesterday and it shows
without a doubt
that there has been no vindication of
donald trump or his campaign
now we know well let me back up we
already knew from the mueller report
that donald trump was not exonerated on
obstruction we knew that from mueller's
report
but this report from the senate select
committee goes so much further remember
as we dive into this
this is a senate controlled by
republicans right now this is not some
left-wing partisan
perspective although certainly democrat
mark warner played a big role in seeing
this through
republican richard burr seems to have
behaved relatively morally
in all of this but even without full
cooperation
from the white house and whoever else
what the report uncovers is extensive
and it's just not getting the attention
it deserves
despite paul manafort's lies throughout
the investigation
they confirmed that paul manafort and
constantine
kilimnik a russian agent were in daily
contact
during the trump campaign they were
coordinating period they were
communicating through encrypted
technology
designed to automatically erase their
correspondence after it took place wow
that's interesting but the real
bombshell here
is that kilimnik was likely a player in
the kremlin plan
to hack and leak the hillary clinton
emails yes
oleg deripaska was connected to the
hacking
but vladimir putin directed the way
in which the hack was going to be
weaponized and carried out yeah
this is what the report found putin knew
and was directing at a high level
this is according to a senate committee
controlled by republicans
yes roger stone and julian assange from
wikileaks were intermediaries to all of
this
so you can come back and say but david
trump and putin didn't personally set
anything up i don't know who alleged
that they did
certainly not on this program roger
stone knew
as early as august of 2016 that
wikileaks had hacked john podesta's
emails
and when the access hollywood grab em by
the you know what tape came out
they decided let's dump these now
because the timing is opportune the
report exposes that trump lied
in his written testimony to robert
mueller about not remembering
conversations with roger stone of course
since then trump has
commuted the sentence of roger stone in
stone's conviction
so again expectations and avoiding
hyperbole
we by that i mean reasonable people
like me said from day one guys
that this is not going to lead to donald
trump's removal
if you're expecting the russia probe to
uncover video of trump red-handed
colluding with putin personally
that was never going to happen because
it didn't happen
if you were expecting trump to be
removed because of the investigation
that was never going to happen
but if you believe and i think as early
as april of 2017 i was saying that
but if you believe that trump basically
has a thing for putin
and other dictators and he's just easy
to manipulate
and the trump campaign was connected to
russia
through wikileaks in this hacking and a
lot of other details
the senate report finds that it did
happen and don't forget trump asked on
live tv
that russia hacked hillary's emails they
did that wasn't trivial that
actually you don't have to look too deep
he said it publicly
and it's what happened and manafort was
in touch with kilimnik and it it all
happened okay
so then the question is what now nothing
i mean they're not going to be held
accountable just put it out of your mind
the accountability would be
voting trump out in november relegating
trump to being
a one-term president who leaves after
one term
with a disastrous record and embarrassed
of course he will because of his
narcissism find some way out of it but
who cares
it's for the good of the country that's
what we have left either trump has made
a one-term president
or trump is rewarded with another four
years that's what it is
sunday is the 15th anniversary of the
david pakman show we'll be doing a
one-day membership special
i hope you'll partake a sign on to our
newsletter
at davidpakman.com and sunday afternoon
you'll get an email telling you
how to take advantage of this insane
possibly illegal certainly immoral
membership discount just get uh grab
that newsletter subscription for free
at davidpakman.com the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they
do is take thousands of popular
nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in
15 minutes blinkist makes sure that
you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are
malcolm riordan and laura cowell
thanks to both of you and also an extra
special thank you to richard wilson
who's today's long time sustaining
member of the day richard's been a
member
for almost five years you can join right
now there's really nothing holding you
back
at joinpakman.com we have some great
discussions happening on the david
pakman show subreddit which you can find
at davidpakman.com
reddit interestingly because of what the
next story is
one user ethan a says it's time
david does a deep dive into q and on
and um ethan writes at first i
understood the sentiment of not wanting
to give these unfounded insane beliefs
any attention
however that can no longer be the case
and ethan argues that because so many
people are now
uh believing and embracing the q anon
stuff
that it's time for me to deal with it
well donald trump seems to also have
embraced it yesterday during a press
briefing
and so we're going to talk about it
today in fact
user katie all the time asks how will
the u.s
deal with the anti-vaxxers refusing the
vaccine when it comes out
saying one of my fears once a vaccine
for the coronavirus comes out
is that a significant minority will
refuse it soon the anti-massacres
will turn into the anti-vaxxers and
refuse the vaccine if let's say 30
of the us population refuses to take the
vaccine how will the u.s respond
well i i hate to burst what is already
a very bad bubble katie but 40 to 50
percent of americans as of right now say
they will not
take a coronavirus vaccine so i don't
know the answer for coronavirus herd
immunity
based on its level of contagion we need
about 70
immunity in the united states if three
or four percent of the country gets the
virus
you've got to get immunity and build
natural immunity if indeed that's the
way it works
you need about 65 66 of the country to
get vaccinated if only 40 percent plan
two
we have a real problem i don't have an
answer
here in massachusetts the flu vaccine is
going to be mandatory this year
to attend public school a lot of people
are furious they're saying this is
opening the door to mandatory
vaccination
we're going to talk about that on the
bonus show but you're completely right
and in fact katie
i think you are understating the problem
because it's not
30 so far that have said i probably
won't get the vaccine
it's 40 or even 50 in the polls that
i've seen over the last couple of months
ugly ugly ugly stuff join the discussion
on the david pakman show subreddit at
davidpakman.com
slash reddit that's r-e-d-d-i-t
let's now deal with this q anon stuff
so we have reached a new low where
donald trump
will praise anyone absolutely anyone
who says anything positive about him
there is this
thing i hate to even call it that
called q anon some people call it canon
some people call it canon some people
call it quan
anyway q anon q anon is a radical right
conspiracy theory
it involves a deep state plot supposed
against donald trump
a group or a person or an entity named q
claims to have classified information
about it
has made all sorts of allegations it
really hasn't been worth our time to
cover
but it has slowly infected trump rallies
and it has slowly infected trumpism
and it has spread through trump
supporters and it got to the point where
yesterday
donald trump was actually asked about
this during his press briefing
and trump seems to like q anon
and almost endorse q anon despite
claiming
that he doesn't actually know anything
about them take a look at this
during the pandemic uh the q anon
movement has been
appears to be gaining a lot of followers
can you talk about what you think about
that and what you have to say
to people who are following this
movement right now well i don't know
much about the movement other than i
understand they like me very much
[Music]
which i appreciate but i don't know much
about the movement
i have heard that it is gaining in
popularity and from what i hear these
are people that
when they watch the streets of portland
when they watch what happened in new
york city in just the last six or seven
months but this was starting
even four years ago when i came here
almost four years can you believe it
these are people that don't like seeing
what's going on in
places like portland and places like
chicago
and new york and other cities and states
and i've heard these are people that
love our country and they just don't
like seeing it
so i don't know really anything about it
other than
they do supposedly like me
and they also would like to see
problems in these areas like especially
the areas that we're talking about
go away i've heard these people love our
country this is
really close to an endorsement of q anon
if you can imagine something so
outrageous
then the reporter smartly follows up and
says well you know
q anon claims that you donald trump
are saving the world from a satanic
cult of pedophilia and cannibalism
is that something that you're doing and
trump still sort of says
hey you know me as a savior of the world
that that sounds pretty good trump
can't get away from anybody who says
anything positive about trump no matter
how outrageous or laced
with conspiracies take a look theory it
is this belief that
you are secretly saving the world from
this satanic
cult of pedophiles and cannibals does
that sound like something
you are behind well i haven't i
haven't heard that but uh is that
supposed to be a bad thing or a good
thing i mean you know
if if i can help save the world from
problems i'm
willing to do it i'm willing to put
myself out there and we are
actually we're saving the world from a
radical left
philosophy that will destroy this
country and when this country
is gone the rest of the world would
follow
the rest of the world would follow the
president is certainly not saying
that's insane and i denounce it okay the
president is certainly not saying
anything that they say about me is false
what trump is saying is they sound like
good people
they like me they love our country
and they say i'm saving the world from
things while i am saving the world from
things that doesn't sound so bad
i really hope that people understand how
absolutely outrageous this is this
is similar to a president endorsing
pizzagate
this is similar to a president embracing
birth there is
oh oh trump's oh yikes
okay yeah well birtherism that that too
i read that
um jeb bush was horrified
that donald trump seemed to endorse q
this is not jeb bush's republican party
anymore but jeb bush does bear
responsibility
for this being the republican party as
of today and and i think that that's
really
where i want to focus our time this is
why i keep
bringing up that after donald trump is
gone whenever it is
whether it's january or january of 2025
or as trump recently suggested getting a
third term
january of 2029 that's a joke by the way
the republican party is really going to
have to figure out what do we do with
the trumpists
if trump loses in november he will lose
despite
60 million or 62 or 64 or 66 million
people voting for him
what does the republican party do with
those 60 plus million people
who want trump re-elected what does the
country do
with the 60 million people is a
different question which i don't have an
answer to
but as far as the republican party this
is what happens when you welcome any
lunatic
who is willing to vote against democrats
for decades
the anti-abortionists come on in the
homophobes
come on in the cartoonish libertarians
come on in
the white nationalists the conspiracy
theorists the religious nuts selling
silver solution right
everybody come on in well they're here
now and they selected trump in the 2016
primary
and they're reaping what they've sown
and oh now jeb bush doesn't like it
colin powell doesn't like it as far as
jeb bush
if jeb bush is concerned about what he's
hearing
from donald trump come out publicly and
say
we have to vote for joe biden where's
george w
bush we know george w bush is not
endorsing trump
he's not participating in the
presidential election
and is reportedly disturbed by some of
the things donald trump has done and
said
why doesn't george w bush come out and
say for the sake of our country
we must all vote for joe biden
this time around and then lastly on the
press briefing just as like a cherry on
top
uh trump still seems to think that
stealth airplanes which of course
they're invisible to radar trump still
seems to think that they're invisible to
the naked eye
take a look at this is it very difficult
i was asking a pilot what do you think
is better this one this one that one
talking about russian plans chinese
planes
he said well the advantage we have is
you can't see it
so when we're fighting they can't see us
i see that sounds like a really
big advantage to me this is where we are
today
this is where we are today and we may
have four more years of this
it's a real possibility it's up to us to
prevent it we're going to have more on
this on the david pakman show
instagram which is david pakman show on
instagram
you can follow me on instagram why would
you follow me
i don't know but you can see pictures
and updates of my urban garden my cukes
and my zoops i've got eight inchers 10
inchers footlongs it's
crazy what's going on out there with my
cukes and zuks follow me
on instagram at david.pakman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous bonus show as well as commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome back to the
program tom hartman who's the host of
the thom hartmann program and also
author of the new book the hidden
history of monopolies how big business
destroyed the american dream tom as
always great to see you
thank you david the book has a forward
by ralph nader too which is
uh the forward is almost worth the cost
of the book it's amazing
i i've actually spoken to ralph nader
about about this issue
and um many people i mean maybe a good
place to start is
i don't know that everybody understands
how far back monopolies and monopolistic
behavior by firms in the united states
goes you talk about it dating all the
way back to the revolution which may
surprise some people
yeah the boston tea party was a revolt
against a monopolistic company the east
india company was the largest
uh monopoly in the world at the time
uh they had monopolized tea in the
united states along with a lot of other
things
it was illegal to manufacture fine
clothing in the united states for
example certain types of weaponry
certain certain types of furniture they
all had to be manufactured in england
and imported
by the east india company and so when
the
depression or recession of 1770 hit
the the east india company petitioned
the british government
for basically some cash they were
stretched
and the british government uh said uh
we'll give you a refund on millions of
dollars worth of tea
that you've got in today's dollars that
you have in in
inventory because they back then they
paid tax when they received the t
from india not when they sold it and uh
so the east india company got this huge
multi-million dollar
tax rebate that allowed them to drop
their price on t
into the united states and compete with
the with the american smugglers
which made the american people just
furious
and uh thus the tea party in our our
nation was
birthed in a revolt against corporate
monopoly
when we think about the different times
in american history
where there's been more of a focus on
trust busting
and going after monopolies are there
certain industries that have regularly
sort of skirted the scrutiny that maybe
they deserve
well there are some industries that have
been better at it than others and that
it tends to
have to do with how much political power
they have which is usually a consequence
of either financial power or
essential industry you know banks or
pharmaceutical companies for example
but you know the the simple reality is
that um
you know just like cancer in the body is
when one cell decides i'm going to take
over the entire body and starts
growing and growing and growing without
limit and
redirecting all the resources of the
body to itself until it ultimately kills
the body
monopoly is cancer within capitalism
and our bodies have an immune system
that you know we're constantly every day
where
our bodies are producing cancerous cells
in our immune system is gobbling them up
this is just a normal part
of uh you know biology well similarly
you know we developed an immune system
and capitalism is really in its modern
form only about 300 years old
and back in the 1880s here in the united
states we developed an immune system
following on what had been done in
europe just before um to that cancer of
monopoly which was the sherman antitrust
act and then later
in the 1930s the clayton antitrust act
and then the 1956
antitrust act or anti-monopoly law
and uh you know it worked it worked
fairly well
uh but the problem was in 1982 in 1983
ronald reagan ordered the justice
department the sec and the commerce
department to stop enforcing those laws
and that led to this explosion of
consolidation the mergers and
acquisition mania those people old
enough to remember
it uh it was a wild time michael milken
and you know greed is good and all this
stuff
and all these companies being jammed
together and the workers being fired the
pension puns
funds being stolen most people remember
the airlines twday
and eastern and you know they got gutted
this way but it happened in
every sector of american business and
now here 40 years later
there is not literally not one single
industrial sector or major uh sector
of the american economy left that is not
dominated by three to five
large companies that control sixty to
eighty percent of the total revenue
and operate as functionally as a
monopoly
technically you'd call it an oligopoly
and as a result of this the average
american family is paying about five
thousand dollars a year more
for the goods and services that they buy
than they would if we didn't have a
monopoly
internet service for example in europe
is typically 25 to 30
a month for you know one gigabyte up and
down here in the united states you paid
two to three times that
because we've got just a you know a
handful of internet service providers
now
um you know yeah i wanted to ask about
the 5000 because i think that that's
interesting so
when when you you write in the book that
the the monopoly in the united states
essentially
ex expands or increases the amount that
the average
family spends on a yearly basis by five
thousand dollars and what you're talking
about there would be
well on internet it might be an
additional sixty dollars a month
times twelve there you've got seven
twenty what are what are the other
areas where cell phone services
pharmaceuticals
um you know basically everything except
cheap junk from
china and and uh and and what the cheap
junk from china has
succeeded in doing is running out of
business
literally thousands of american american
companies uh
you know since the 1980s we've been
losing um you know on average seven
eight hundred factories a year
in some cases thousands of factories a
year we were up to losing five thousand
factories a year uh you know after the
city after signing nafta
and and each one of those factories
represents hundreds to thousands in some
cases
even tens of thousands of jobs you know
according to the commerce department
according to our official statistics
we've lost millions of jobs to to uh to
this kind of
monopolistic behavior only in this case
the monopoly is another country
you know and and you know a little help
from walmart and their friends
so uh you know it's right across the
board david
how has the um when you look at the lack
of appetite
to really deal with this in the united
states dating back for some time you
talked about ronald reagan you've talked
about it in the 18th century
is it as simple as a sort of version
of regulatory capture and a calculation
from those in empowered that this is
just not
where their regulatory uh oversight is
um an area that they want to focus or is
is there more to it than that well by
and large that's how it's played out
but they're they're as usual the story
is is a little more complicated and a
little
seemier and weirder um you know back in
the 1960s
uh milton friedman was teaching at the
university of chicago and
or you know was at the university of
chicago and one of his uh
students robert bork uh got all
uh inflamed about this idea all you know
hair on fire about this idea that he had
learned from milton friedman that
that uh we shouldn't traditionally
america had viewed a corporation as
having multiple constituencies a
corporation had a responsibility to the
community in which it operated
to not mistreat that community or
pollute it to its employees to pay them
well
and and you know serve them to its
customers to make sure its customers
weren't you know ripped off or burned
um to the institution of the corporation
itself
and to its shareholders and senior
management
and bork came along and said all that is
nonsense you guys have complicated this
way too much it's really simple if
consumers pay less
then it's not a monopoly and uh you know
people thought he was a crackpot in the
sixties but he persisted he wrote a book
about it he testified to congress
he engaged a multi-year major lobbying
campaign
and by the time reagan tried to put him
on the supreme court
and we discovered that he not only was a
crackpot but also a racist and a
homophobe
um you know by that time the supreme
court in the 1970s in a case called gte
sylvania
had concluded that bork was right and
that you know and that reagan was right
and that we're going to set all this
stuff aside and we're only going to
enforce the anti-monopoly laws based on
whether prices are going up for
consumers
of course since then prices have gone up
and consumers tremendously
but you know basically the the
enforcement was killed
so we're back right now where we were in
1900 you know and and you know we're
faced with a situation like the one that
teddy roosevelt and william howard taft
took on
correct me if i'm wrong but it seems
that that the coronavirus pandemic has
really accelerated the consolidation
of market share um for the players that
were already some of the biggest players
i mean we're seeing with amazon
walmart places that immediately uh
scaled up
uh particularly those that are that that
use if they're using these third-party
sprinter vans to deliver stuff that is a
sign if you work
backwards that those are the the the
players
that are increasing market share and i
just don't know like
we would need a total rethink of the
economy to prevent that from naturally
happening in a situation like the one we
find ourselves in right i mean if
it from my perspective what the virus
exposed was
that a bunch of the economy is
significantly more
fragile than what we like to believe on
a day-to-day basis
and as soon as that became clear those
that were positioned
to seize on the opportunity have done so
yeah i mean the reason why so many aids
patients died of karposis or komak a
cancer
is because their immune system has been
shut down and you know so cancer could
grow in the body
um the reason why monopoly has now
seized america
and our economy has been run by a couple
hundred billionaires
is because that is because ronald reagan
stripped away our immune system
he he gave us the the business
equivalent of aids
and and you know our country is
suffering terribly for it
uh we've got to bring back that immune
system we've got to be pushing back
against the cancer of monopoly
so what's the infrastructure that you
think needs needs to be put in place is
it as simple as just
enforcing what is on the books or do we
actually need
a new framework in which we are going to
approach this issue
well as is so often the case with with
um
you know pro structural problems in
modern america so much of this goes back
to the supreme court
uh you know my last book was all about
that and and actually the book before
last
and uh you know between the court in 78
76 and 78
giving billionaires and corporations the
right to own politicians and entire
political parties and calling it free
speech
um combined with the gte sylvania case
where the court
re you know re-understood explicit
you know monopoly laws the anti-monopoly
laws explicitly talk about these
multiple constituencies and
how you determine you know everything
and the court just said oh you know
we're going to ignore all that and go
with robert bork
um you know we need legislation that
includes a court stripping provision
which i write about my supreme court
book that overturns
that supreme court decision and the ones
that have followed
and that re-regulates american business
in a way that prevents it from being
cancerous
if you uh have the idea that
if joe biden wins in november and puts
somebody like elizabeth warren who has
spoken about the issue of monopoly
as secretary of commerce for example or
or in some regulatory role
is it naive to think that that alone
might make a difference like is this
just way bigger than that
i think that america is poised on the
edge of the possibility
of a of a of another great renewal
it seems like roughly every 80 years we
go through a crisis
and then as we come out of the crisis on
the back end weeks we experience
a renewal explosion uh you had the
crisis of 1770 it led to the american
revolution you had the crisis of the
civil war and the oligarchy in the south
and that led to the civil war but also
led to all
the changes the post-civil war changes
very positive changes
um you had the the great crash of 1929
the republican great depression
that led to the new deal and all those
changes um you know
a smaller crisis the assassination of
jack kennedy led to
medicare medicaid civil rights act
voting rights act etc
and i think that the crisis of the trump
presidency in this giant
drifter on job the billionaires have
been running on us
um has set the stage for a renewal the
question is number one can we get a
democrat elected now or has trump so
corrupted americans
uh america's electoral systems that that
he's gonna you know turn us into
uh you know uh trumpistan um and number
two
if we do get a democratic administration
whether they will have the
the the vision and the boldness to go
ahead
if if elizabeth warren is at the helm or
is you know has a substantial say in it
wherever that may be and however it may
play out
i'm very enthusiastic and very excited
and very hopeful
if she gets marginalized and it becomes
you know basically a reinvention of the
clinton and obama presidencies that were
deeply in the pockets of large
corporations
then um you know i'm i'm concerned but
that's a that's a debate and a
discussion we can have once we
once we uh put our uh you know our house
is on fire right now
fire out yeah first you put the fire out
before you figure out how to do
how to fix what what what's been burned
let's go
discuss how to paint the rooms yeah
exactly yeah right yeah the the
searching for that uh analogy and you
you found it
last last thing on this um there's an
entire political movement in the united
states which heavily fetishizes the idea
of
eliminating regulation which is
hampering and restricting business
etc etc how much of this is going to be
an uphill battle until that starts to be
dealt with as well
well this is where we've got a big job
to do in educating the american people
because the simple fact of the matter is
that
there is only one force on earth
that can constrain or restrain a billion
dollar corporation when it wants to
pollute the water
put poison in the air kill people with
crappy products
oppress workers and and rip off their
employees
there's only literally one power on
earth that can fight back against that
and that's government
and you know the the right-wing
billionaires you know the koch brothers
and their buddies
back in the day knew that they
understood that and when their boy
ronald reagan got elected they you know
in his first inaugural address
for you know minutes after he was sworn
into office his first speech he said
government is not the solution to your
problem government
is the problem he laid the the he set
the table
for this destruction of america that's
been going on for 40 years
and and you know it is some serious
repair work that needs to be done but i
think if enough people wake up and
realize how badly we have been harmed by
this
bizarre small government ideology that
was only promoted over these 40 years by
people who simply wanted to be able to
pollute and poison and rip off
with impunity then i think that there's
some considerable hope
the book is the hidden history of
monopolies how big
business destroyed the american dream
we've been speaking with the book's
author tom hartman
tom it's always so good to talk to you
thank you david it's always an honor and
a pleasure to be on your program
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
this next story is sort of the perfect
epitome of
everything that is donald trump
according to the former department of
homeland security
chief of staff miles taylor donald trump
floated the idea of swapping puerto rico
for greenland in order to get rid of
some of those
poor puerto ricans from dirty puerto
rico
yeah this combines like three or four
different stories so
first of course is trump's obvious
disregard for puerto rico we saw this
during hurricane response in the past
you might remember donald trump
showing up in puerto rico and shooting
rolls of paper towels like basketballs
then there's the idea of the [ __ ]
country which
mostly are countries with brown people
and then there's the idea of trump being
interested in acquiring greenland which
is something that came up i don't know
if it was six months ago or 12 months
ago just time feels so strange at this
point and
lastly kind of tying it all together
is donald trump's completely deranged
world view
his delusions of grandeur his narcissism
his complete lack of empathy so
let's first go to the tape here is miles
taylor former department of homeland
security
chief of staff telling the story himself
on msnbc
tear gas at the border etc i'm wondering
what is the most in the conversations
you're involved in disturbing
idea or thought or discussion that you
heard from president trump that is sort
of resonating and sitting with you
still today we could probably go on for
days about that although i'm going to
tell you one thing that just popped into
my head hallie
there was a time when of course we were
spending a lot of our days
down in puerto rico after the hurricanes
uh devastation down there
u.s virgin islands uh and other places
there was a trip that we made down there
in august of 2018
and i remember before we went uh the
president said something
and your viewers are going to be
somewhat familiar with this the
president's talked before
about wanting to purchase greenland but
one time before we went down he told us
not only did he want to purchase
greenland he actually said he wanted to
see if we could sell puerto rico
could we swap puerto rico for greenland
because in his words
puerto rico was dirty and the people
were poor these are americans hallie
and we don't talk about our fellow
americans that way so this is really
pretty wild and completely
unconscionable and really something to
contend with it
it has to be an anecdote for some kind
of hall of fame although i don't know
what we would be commemorating in this
hall of fame it wouldn't be anything
good but it seems like that anecdote is
historic in some sense
and i'm reminded of what michelle obama
told us
during her dnc speech on the first night
of the democratic national convention
monday which was
if you think things couldn't possibly
get any worse
they can and they will if we don't make
a change this election now
merely as a thought experiment if puerto
rico
got to become part of denmark the way
greenland
is part of denmark now puerto ricans
might actually be better off because my
guess
is denmark wouldn't do to puerto rico or
neglect puerto rico
in the way that donald trump has
neglected puerto rico
so from the standpoint of the puerto
rican people
it may be interesting to them to
actually become part of denmark but of
course
this is completely crazy in every sense
and it's very funny to hear the right
continue to insist
that latino voters are just they're on
the verge they're so close of becoming
republicans
and abandoning the democratic party then
you hear this and it's very hard to
fathom that that's the case
and of course cubans are the most
conservative
latino group in the united states other
than
cubans there is very little
republicanism
among latino voters puerto ricans
dominicans mexicans argentinians so on
and so forth
and and then by the way everybody who
talked about
we need a business person running the
country like a business
this is what you get this is what you
get when you have someone who says
if a piece of my business isn't
interesting if a
piece of my business is a loss leader if
it's not
profitable or whatever let me see if i
can find
some sucker to offload it to or sell it
to
and that's how you get a president who
says maybe i could trade puerto rico for
greenland
um we i used the term earlier we we are
reaping what we've sown and that is
exactly what you see in this story
there's a very interesting new poll from
the university of
southern california which is making
headlines because joe biden is winning
by 11.
i don't want to talk about that i've
already told you you know joe up 11 with
a margin of error of three and a half
means maybe joe is only up four
and if trump picks up a point between
now and november you could have the
exact same outcome as in 2016. so i
don't care about biden up by 11.
what i care about in this poll is that
it looks
at non-voters from 2016 okay
in the united states embarrassingly
tragically disgustingly only about 55
percent of eligible voters
vote 45 percent of those who could vote
did not vote in 2016. the turnout was
55 percent the preliminary data
from the university of southern
california poll finds that
among those who didn't vote in 2016
but plan to vote this year 52 percent
plan to vote for joe biden while only 32
percent plan to vote for donald trump
and another 16 say that they would vote
third party
now it's also notable that among those
who voted
third party in 2016 they are also
leaning towards biden
41 of those who were third party in 2016
are going biden while only 30 percent
of 2016's third party voters are going
for donald trump
that's huge and uh of the people
when you combine that 71 percent
of third-party voters from last election
are not voting third party this time
around which i think does go to
the understood significance of this
election
but i want to focus on the non-voters
okay 2016 non-voters who are going to
vote are leaning towards biden
the obvious question is how many people
is that
right if there's a hundred thousand
non-voters
from last time who are going to vote
that's very
different than if there are 10 million
non-voters from 2016
who plan to vote uh if indeed 52
of them are going to be voting for joe
biden and just as importantly
how many people are there who did vote
in 2016 and don't plan to
this time around no data on them another
important question but this is another
signal
that our instinct from a year and a half
ago continues to be proven true
we are way better off trying to just
mobilize people to vote
than we are trying to argue with
trumpists to get them to change their
minds
it's very clear that a majority of those
who didn't vote last time
if we can get them to participate that
helps joe biden
just finding non-voters from 2016 and
getting them to vote
helps joe biden if you can target it to
people who are already on the left but
didn't vote
that's the win spending time arguing
with trumpists
whose brains have turned to mayonnaise
uh is not a good electoral strategy and
then we get to the problem of voter
apathy in the united states
there is no question you know when when
45 percent of the
elect eligible voting public doesn't
vote
there's no question that part of the
problem is
we are not ingraining civic engagement
and the importance of voting
from a young age where if people are
growing up in households where
of course you vote is the default
if kids are not hearing in school as
early as whenever
we vote that is what you do if he
if that was the situation our turnout
would be far higher than 55
that's one part of the problem our
voting system is also part of the
problem and we can't ignore that the
system we have dissuades voting
and if you look at other countries
without mandatory voting
uh with significantly higher turnout you
see that sometimes they have different
election systems new zealand has a mixed
member proportional system
their turnout last election was almost
80 percent germany has a mixed member
proportional system
their turnout was 76 percent we have a
first-past-the-post system
that perpetuates the two-party duopoly
and
dissuades voting at all now many of you
have called me during live calls and you
say
david what the hell is going on with
third parties why can't third parties
get going in the united states
part of it is the spoiler effect of the
first past the post
post system and part of it also is
campaign finance so there are many
problems here
i don't believe that the intent of the
founding fathers
was to create a system that dissuades
participation
but it's what it's become in the modern
voting era
from the standpoint of this election
let's target those who didn't vote last
time it's a good idea the data backs it
up
we can't bank on non-voters showing up
some of the least reliable voters
are people who didn't vote last time
unfortunately but
the numbers are on our side arguing with
trumpists is a waste of time
and the numbers show non-voters from
2016
much more likely to support joe biden
than donald trump
i think it's an interesting area to
focus on particularly
in battleground states from here on out
we have a voicemail number which is 2192
david p
here is yet another question about 2020
and donald trump
hey david have a quick question
theoretically
yes trump spends the next four years
building his base even more
could you run for president again and
fulfill his second term four years later
can you legally do that within the
constitution within our
laws yes you can so the question is if
trump loses now and biden's president
four years could trump run in 2024 he
could i don't think he will
i think if listen if trump loses he is a
narcissist
he will have to justify his loss he
can't just say i lost i lost because
people didn't want me
i lost because i messed up trump will
justify it and say
i didn't want it anyway screw you guys
i've got better things to do etc trump
will be nearly 80 in 2024.
trump is not going to run in 2024 if he
loses this is it
okay this is the opportunity we can get
trump out and that will be it for donald
trump now
don jr or eric or ivanka who the hell
knows that's another story we'll cross
that bridge when we come to it
but this is it if trump is not president
the next four years
that is it for trump's presidency we've
got a great bonus show for you today
so many great stories i hope you'll join
me on the bonus show
and remember that you can get instant
access to that world famous
bonus show by becoming a member at
jointpakman.com
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor
is blinkist the app that lets you read
or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 off of a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video